oh my god this is so gross I like it
one thing I've learned in my informative
albeit chaotic adult ears is that no two
relationships are the same hey Devin
yeah
stillness Oh some couples like Jared and
I balance each other out like yin and
yang like sugar and spice who's who
again I'm spicy you're the sugar that's
really sweet but also stop moving thank
you but what happens when two people are
equal parts crazy and artistry do they
explode or does their dark star of a
relationship burn on for eons
this is history bites a show where Jared
and I mix our obsession with each other
with our obsession with food and old
romance Jared recruits the dishes left
behind by notable celebrities while I
dish on their love life on this episode
were exploring the relationship between
Salvador Dali and his wife slash muse
gala are we done yet yeah let me see
check her out pretty true to life hey I
love her
so Jared what makes a healthy
relationship hmm
kale apples turmeric that is so cheesy I
can't okay this is the crux of this
episode deciding whether or not this
couple had a healthy relationship and by
the way let me just start by saying I
don't know if it's gala or gala so I'm
probably gonna mess it up I'm so sorry
if anyone's really offended probably the
gala Apple people heaven forbid those
are my favorite so today we're gonna do
one cocktail and one entree a lot of
these recipes are inspired by the dinner
parties that he and gala used to row at
their house we're doing eggs on a spit a
very complicated recipe technically yeah
this shoot may age me 50 years we don't
know we'll see basically what we're
gonna do is par cook the eggs in a pan
with a bunch of other stuff and then
shove that mixture back into the egg
shells put them all on little spit roast
them and then serve them like that okay
the cocktail for the day is called the
Casanova cocktail so let's start doing
this whole foods didn't have fresh
ginger so I got minced ginger you ever
seen I am shook because their love story
is so fascinating I really want to Ken
Burns their backstory I get to the juicy
stuff the orange juice that will be in
this cocktail eater I'm sorry dad jokes
born in a Salvador Dali was born May
11th 1904 and he go to Spain as Salvador
Felipe has seen two dull EE Dominic gala
Dali was born no I'm gonna I'm just
gonna butcher this this they have so
many names and they're so European
please just look it up he's very Spanish
she's very Russian
her exact birth date is unknown but her
daughter said that she was born August
18th 1894 so off the bat we know that
she is a Leo and we know that she is 10
years to senior a double cougar oh cool
okay next we're gonna add a pinch of
cayenne pepper for the booze is so we're
gonna do some brandy and some bitters
which I got some Campari so let's start
with dolly in his early life he studied
art in Barcelona and Madrid he really
didn't develop his artistic style until
his 20s around the same time that he
discovered the work of Sigmund Freud
gala was very good student but at the
time they didn't provide higher
education for women I have a quote about
gala that I want to read gala always
felt more comfortable in the shadows but
like dolly she also wanted to become a
legend one day gala was the focal point
of mythology's paintings sketches and
great means have you ever been the
subject of an engraving before I rarely
even show up in the subject of emails we
don't have muddlers but this is you
Medellin this is me making sure we get
every last spicy bit also this is mostly
brandy which is stressing me up we're
definitely gonna drink these after we
poked the holes in the eggs and refilled
them right yeah we need to be centered
clear ready to fail
great okay so I popped those in the
fridge we're gonna wait about 30 minutes
and I found aprons we can't do this
about cute apron thank gosh it's time
for eggs time for eggs a dreaded moment
eggshells they know if you're scared of
them and they'll just break in your
hands I'm not afraid of you not freely I
brought this for you
yeah you're welcome you're gonna poke a
little hole in one end and a little hole
in the other end oh my god yeah okay
it's happening alright oh did you do it
how are we supposed to get big back in
this egg is officially empty
you've done it I did it faster than me
I'm impressed
so gala was married with a daughter when
she first met Salvador Dali but don't
let this little ring fool you gala and
her first husband for who all intensive
purposes was one of the forefathers of
the surrealist movement and an
interesting situation some say she had
extramarital affairs
no snow tably with Dadaist painter mac
skirts like there is an article written
by Cecile where she remembers
her mom and her dad and her mom's
boyfriend all living in the same home
who a surrealist Three's Company
right well it what a trip they didn't
have the vocabulary for open marriages
back then but like whatever the
situation was she orchestrated it so it
could work for her she was getting what
she needed and what she wanted exactly
history does not really remember her in
the best light stop why yeah it's off
her contemporaries went on record saying
that they did not care for her some have
insinuated that she had a penchant for
young artists well obviously and that
she was a social climber and it has been
inclined that many men and women were
threatened by her forceful demeanor as
well as her sexual freedom I want to
just go on record and say that I noticed
but a lot of these critiques a man we're
like a surrealist painting right now
what next inside of egg time in fact so
gallant
Salvador Dali met in 1929 Salvador Dali
invited a bunch of surrealist artists
and literary figures over to his humble
abode for the summer
Paul Lu out Dallas husband right now and
a bunch of others all went to Spain
Salvador Dali at that time was in the
middle of a mental breakdown and decided
to invite people over I think he sent
the invitation before yeah he like
wasn't speaking he wasn't painting galas
steps in and she goes to talk to him
this is a quote by Salvador Dali about
that moment she was destined to be my
Kavita the one who moves forward my
victory my wife you made it you made it
really nice I mean I'm paying a lot of
student loans for this acting degree I
got apparently after they met that
summer his artistic well was full the
porch lights were back on and gala
likewise was drawn to Dolly's genius she
wanted something
something which would be the fulfillment
of her own myth and this thing that she
wanted was something that she was
beginning to think that perhaps only I
could give her you know he really didn't
like touch a lot of his friends talked
about how if he were in his presence you
did not touch him physical touch felt
I'm playing no mind getting in his
mindset no on a very touch ok so they
had off the bat a very cerebral very
emotional connection I just think this
is an important thing to talk about
because I think when we think of like
explosive relationships our mind off of
goes to the physical but with these two
it was something very different that's
really nice yeah they seem like total
crazies but they found each other
yeah crazies that found each other
that's all one can really hope for right
as a fellow crazy we found each other
deserts sacred I like just how we're
like emotional I think we're ready to
start throwing this together I'm scared
so Dolly was famous for his method of
how he painted it was called the
paranoiac critical method sounds painful
we as rational human beings don't like
think about clocks melting but Dollywood
because he would work himself up put
himself in this space and then just
start painting Galef found him in this
state when he was like already paranoid
I was able to kind of like help him a
get through it and be make him lucrative
because she was his business manager
loved her lovage ER I come at you with
they claim basically gala dolly
abandoned her daughter and her first
husband to be with Salvador which is not
our you know Yahoo know that said I
don't really want to judge kiss I don't
know her life you know what I mean his
family did not approve of their
relationship they were married in a
ceremony like pretty shortly after they
met each other but then they had only
had like an official wedding with
paperwork and everything years later
I finally came to terms with the fact
that gala was in the picture and she
wasn't going nowhere interesting this is
all coming together very quickly yeah so
Cherie turn the heat down oh you turned
it back up again when I wasn't looking I
did not I actually did I didn't maybe I
did I can't remember at this point it's
all happening so fast
this recipes wild I've never put so much
butter in anything in my life but I'm
not mad it's gonna add a lot of richness
and I think it's gonna make it like a
pipe of all texture we're gonna soften
this whole mixture up just a little bit
more and now we're gonna put this on a
piping bag
and squish it back on into those little
eggy shells you look so nervous I am
very nervous because we're working with
eggshells here people it's okay when
you're filling a piping bag unroll it a
little bit because then it kind of stays
sturdy this is like your own little T
bit this is hot ow how do they do this
oh it's not that hot you just wait or am
I just a sensitive boy I know the answer
to that question you don't have to say
anything
Ready Steady Go she's beautiful she's
our child I love her we did it we're
doing it it's happening it's I love this
this is really good for me it's this
good for you no that one was really good
that was amazing I was so happy I do
enjoy a scene he's so happy filling
these eggs with goop
[Music]
six beautiful eggs so now we got to put
skewers and these babies I got us some
clean skewers I'm gonna go through the
small end it's cracking oh no Devon
don't ruin it
so another incredible thing I want to
talk to you about about dahlias he
waived the way for artists to really
think of themselves as brands after him
you think about like Andy Warhol in the
factory scene there was no separation of
Dolly the man and Dolly the artist he
was a new up stars of the day
exactly pop stars the person who had a
really big part in developing that brand
was Galah okay okay I did I did I did it
I did it I did it you know what I was
confident I just like rammed it in there
I like who made it happen eggs
be safe okay now we're gonna roast these
in the oven ten minutes for ten minutes
since we can't do it over an open flame
which I'm so sad about then we get to
drink a cocktail and thought about the
cocktail I need it so badly
bye okay now that Jared's gone we should
probably say font though actually in
case it we mess it up no I just thought
of that now after egg time booze time
all right so all we need to do to finish
these is put the juice of one orange
into each so I got two oranges I'm just
waiting for you to get out of my way
they're just a one-off it's us wait to
Salvador's inside
it's our doing we're here to Sal and his
gal just found his gal I love that
that's really spicy that's a very strong
it's definitely overwhelmingly brandy
Eve yeah I taste a lot of brandy it has
a lot of ginger I hit me in the head
already I'm not mad at this though I'm
not mad it feels like a juice cleanse
Plus outlaw is so I'm into it Salvador
Dali was really big into plating and how
he presented as an artist yeah it makes
a lot of sense so we gotta figure out a
creative way to plate these I grab some
things from props to play with but our
set decorator put them back there should
we do a little competition to see who
can present it better
[Music]
Oh a balancing act is making me nervous
then I need to clear this I think it's
only fair that we tell you the meaning
behind our presentations Jared where's
our parents our artist statements I'll
go first
so life as we know it is in delicate
balance at all times one day you could
be on top of the world
the next day you can be in the gutter
that elephants are very wise and they
hold our future in balance that was a
part of the experience the presentation
thank you this is worth 4 grand
the story behind mine is I went into the
desert and had a panic attack and this
is what I came up with I think Sal would
approve
I call on try smashing mine open it is a
surprising experience to peel back what
feels like a hard-boiled egg and to see
this consistency it's that is kind of it
oh my god okay shattering it's not the
best idea you definitely need to peel it
it's fun it smells really good it is
really good yeah it tastes like an ER be
scrambled but frittata it looks like a
brain I like that it holds the shape of
the egg shell kind of it does hold the
shape flavors good no raw egg on the
inside fully cooked so I think it's
pretty successful I'm very surprised and
very proud we didn't shatter one egg
oh yeah Marie didn't you know I liked
making it with you I will send Cheers
I like making it with you so while we're
here finishing up gala and Dolly's
marriage grew very tense and their older
age well he bought her a castle in Spain
and he would only come to the castle if
she sent him a written invitation oh
yeah how they dealt with their marriage
I mean that's cool right there's
something romantic about that the last
fact I have for you is gala lunch buried
in a giant chessboard in that castle
cool well I love art people I want to be
buried in 24 Nintendo 64's just like
made into a coffin noted okay I'll have
to think remember that so that's today's
episode of history bytes tell us in the
comments what you'd like to see us cook
next hopefully more eggs no I could
let's do a dessert or like another
cocktail ooh
pie pie or cake Oh take your pie you're
coming with me honey
[Music]